um
embedded in that question is the uh the
soft implication that that tilt is
something which is a discrete point in
time or a discrete function the fact is
it is a it is going to be an ongoing
piece of work so in one sense the fact
that we have already achieved things
like uh or curse the uh the jet
agreement with Japan and Italy and the
UK or accession to cptpp so so to one
extent the answer is yes
but to another extent the answer is
inevitably going to be no because it's
an ongoing piece of work so it doesn't
have a completion date or a completion
point it's about ongoing engagement with
the region hopefully for decades to come
and so the professor that it had now
been delivered um
Omni what is the long-term effect so how
do we judge this in if we want to put
decades terms how do we judge whether
it's being successful in 20 years time
how do we judge if it's been successful
in a year's time well I think
in a very as I say in a very real sense
it has already shown its success our
levels of Engagement with the region are
higher they have been for some time as I
say accession to cptpp are asean
um relationship
um the the fact that I myself have
traveled to the region first foreign
secretary visit to some of the Pacific
Islands that I went to for for decades
um so it is working it is happening uh
ultimately its success will be judged on
whether in decades to come future a
future foreign secretary is as engaged
as I am and the uh the ministerial team
and the officials within the department
are so uh like a lot of things to do
with international relations and
diplomacy there isn't there isn't an
easy hard metric but how we influence
the region is important and we are
seeing increased
um levels of influence in the region I'm
very very pleased that very proud of
that but as I say it's an ongoing piece
of work it's not something you just do
and then stop it's like painting the
fourth Bridge he's got to keep going at
it so if we take out the metrics of
Engagement and interest that
what's the meaningful effect in terms of
British Security in British
many people would say that the
indo-pacific Tilt is all about a
recognition of the hostilities coming
from China so those didn't feature in
your answer in terms of how we would be
safer as a result of this well the the
folks on the indo-pacific is about all
the countries in the end episode it's
not just about China of course China is
a very large influential and significant
player so it would be ridiculous to have
an increased focus on the indo-pacific
and not increase our focus on China but
it's not exclusively about China
um if if I step back to the mansion
house speech that I gave which which was
predominantly about China it made
reference to the fact that part of this
uh folks on the indo-pacific uh is is
about building long-term sustainable
relationships uh good international
relations with the countries of the
indo-pacific because as I said in the
speech the center of gravity of both
world wealth and influence is moving
eastwards and
um there's no point in us trying to
fight that that is a multi-decade long
Trend and I I have every reason to
believe it will continue
so it is in our interests economically
in terms of security relationships to
make sure that we have really strong
long-term embedded relations with the
with the country and indeed the
individuals of that reason that's what
we set about doing we've got some early
wins let's say uh both in terms trade
security August uh fcas
but also they'll be slower
less easily measurable wins as well so
if I reverse it what would be a sign of
failure in 10 years time I intend not to
fail
I'm I would love to say that our
approach with China over the last 10
years had adopted that but the problem
with the golden eras that we thought
that by opening up and showing Market
democracy and showing market economies
that China would see our way of life and
go wow I wish we'd adopt that they
didn't and there was no plan B for if
that failed so what's our plan B if the
inner exhibit tilt doesn't work but also
what does failure look like and what are
we doing to prevent that
so again it's one of these things where
whereby because this is an ongoing piece
of work I think we would fail we would
have failed if we lost interest in that
region reverted to the kind of comfort
blanket relationships
um that are are are perhaps easy to
manage easy to maintain if we just
crumpled back in to just being I don't
know exclusively a G7 focused country I
think that would be an error I think if
we were to recognize if we were to fail
to recognize this is an enduring piece
of work that's going to require us to
evolve our relationships adapt our
relationships that would be a failure if
we try to harvest the benefits too
quickly or too transactionally
um I think that will be a failure so
having the respect to the countries of
the region to know that they would want
from us
continuity and predictability for
decades to come take China for an
example China measures its history in
Millennia not centuries millennia
so if we are not consistent over at
least decades
it just looks as if we're a hamster in a
wheel and that's why I think we need to
we need to be we need to have the both
the self-confidence to say we're a
significant player and these countries
do want to engage with us and they will
want to engage with us for decades to
come sure I don't disagree but I think
the focus very much in that in that
Vision that you're setting out for us is
about relationships and engagement
where's the hard Edge kpis the Pacific
Hills relationships engagement is hard
Edge I I really pushed back on the idea
that that somehow diplomacy uh
developing international relations
developing uh multi-decade long
relationships is somehow the the soft
side of what we do that is
that is a really important
um function it is hard power
but no one's saying it's not important
but what we're saying is when you are
doing programming in the foreign office
you say the hard Edge effect we want to
achieve is A reduced adduction in drug
cycling we want to not see the invasion
of Taiwan uh we want to see less efforts
by the Chinese government to undermine
multilaterals or insert their civil
servants where are the kind of harder if
you wish then rather than hard Edge kpis
well I think there is a balance to be
struck because one of the risks is that
if you if you try and push for kpis that
are too too short-term in your goal you
fall straight into that into that I I
think erroneous belief that this is all
stuff that plays out over over the
course of weeks or months and as I say
um when we're dealing with India for
example uh which has a history in the
culture again that reaches back
Millennia China views itself in
Millennia what we don't want to do what
we must never do is allow ourselves to
be painted by our detractors as being
short-termest and transactional because
if if that perception is allowed to be
embedded then it undermines our ability
to develop those long-term really
meaningful relations so we do have to be
careful now we are about delivery as I
say orcas is a deliverable
cptpp is a deliverable uh as Yan uh
dialogue status is a deliverable uh
trade deals are deliverable so we are
making sure that we have regular
Milestones on this journey but we we've
gotta we've got to think long term we've
got to think long game because that's
what countries of this region do and do
very very well and we need to calibrate
our pace
to theirs rather than I think perhaps
arrogantly dictating that they calibrate
their place to us I agree and that's
exactly what I made about the failures
the last decade but I would just caution
if we don't know what failure looks like
and if we haven't worked out what we're
trying to deter the risk is that we fail
to stop those from happening and final
two questions before I go to Bob if we
have tilted to the indo-pacific why has
there been no meaningful increase in
cssf funding to the Pacific it's gone up
by only two million pounds that's not a
big increase to 11 million every other
geographical cssf pot is tens of
millions and the indo-pacific is 11
million well there's that is one of the
tools that are disposable certainly not
the the only uh the only tools so some
of it is
um over the uh over the past few years
we've increased our diplomatic footprint
uh in that region that's an incredibly
important uh part of it we don't have as
much money as we would like I find me a
secretary of state it wouldn't prefer
more money to play with
um and so cssf funding is a useful tool
but it's not exclusive at all
well that's our operational funding you
know where you want to deliver programs
about security and stability that is the
pot you go to and there isn't an
alternative to it yes but for a lot of
odds but for a lot of the countries in
this region they don't need our money
they don't need all one-time money no
it's not about giving it's not like odor
it's not about giving them money it's
about us operationalizing and delivering
effects sometimes like the host country
knowing but the the delivery of effect
is discharged to our diplomatic Network
so our ambassadors our defense attaches
our trade envoys our
um the home office teams embedded in our
embassies around the world they are
delivering effect and they are
delivering effect every day and the
nature of the country's uh in that part
of the world means that a number of them
don't need the same things that for
example Africa might need or the Western
Balkans might need so comparing
something like cssf which skews itself
towards certain types of interaction
isn't so it's not inappropriate but it
doesn't show the whole picture
will agree to disagree on that one and
very finely before I turn to Bob we've
been very critical in this committee
that the Tilt was a tilt away from the
Middle East perhaps they use the word
tilt in retrospect wasn't the right one
to use because you have to tilt away
from something to tilt towards something
um the Middle East has historic
commitments the UK should be upholding
do you think it's a fair challenge
I think the use of the word I will take
on board the use of the word does imply
a a tilt two and therefore by the
difference definition of tilt away and
this was something in the first
iteration of the IR as the minister for
uh further responsibility and for our
relations in in the Middle East that was
raised with me I've never been a big fan
of the word tilt it's it's a useful
enough word
and I can't think of a frankly a better
word
um but it does imply a zero-sum game and
that is an error because we don't view
it as a zero sum game
um I I've had extensive interactions
with a number of the Middle Eastern
interlocutors that I got to know when I
was the regional minister so for example
during our
repatriation evacuation exercise uh
sorry operation from Sudan I was
speaking with my Saudi opposite number
on not quite a daily basis multiple
times a week so it is as well as rather
than instead of we don't regardless you
mentioned in widely into Pacifica
many visits
to secretary have you visited
uh yes I've been to Qatar I've been to
Bahrain
um and as I say I've had bilateral
meetings we've one of the uh I suppose
because of the sad death of her majesty
the the queen I've had a lot of
opportunity to host uh inward visits
from the region and more celebratory so
I've had quite a lot of face time with
my uh Interrupters in the region I'll be
honest with you and I've had this
conversation with them as well I'm
conscious of the fact that having been
the minister for that region having
visited the region extensively when I
was a regional Minister there were other
parts of the world that I needed to get
to know a little bit better
um hence my recent visit Latin America
and my visit to the Pacific Islands two
areas that I did not know previously but
I do maintain both face to face and
through digital Communications a strong
relationship the region Bob thank you
sir um thanks for being here foreign
I get what you're saying no one is
saying that we should crumple back and
it's vital that clearly that our
alliances for the 21st century
especially in the end of the Pacific are
going to be with allies such as Korea
Japan as well as major states such as
India and traditional States Australia
and ctpp if I get the acronym right then
orcas I think they're brilliant
successes so many congratulations what
frustrates me still is that some of the
flaws I'm afraid I hear in your argument
over China you are right to say that
these people talk in decades I think
that is a truism if not a cliche but but
actually I think we are still remarkably
inconsistent and it's that I'd like to
briefly talk to you about I'm really
confused by our China policy which seems
to me the political version of a push me
pull you that on one hand we see it as a
threat on one hand uh XI is talking
openly about being ready to invade
Taiwan by what 2027 we see China in the
made in China policy wanting greater
independence from the rest of the world
whilst we are at the same time whilst it
is at the same time encouraging a
greater dependency on China itself from
past another and other states and so
just looking at Supply chains and China
is a really big issue but we can't
haven't got time to talk about all of it
maybe today so just looking at supply
chain dependency I just find the
government's disinterest in our
increasing dependency on Supply chains
whether it's incredibly trivial and
unimportant things like 83 apparently of
our Christmas trees come from China I'm
not going to lose any sleep about that
but on stuff like cellular modules on
stuff like you know all the um the the
the Machinery of of green technologies
we are becoming increasingly dependent
on one country I wouldn't like if that
was Australia or the United States so
why are we allowing this and not even
questioning so when people like me said
let's have a statement on dependency
let's look into this let's try diversify
Supply Supply chains I I just get a sort
of shrug of the shoulders still from
from government sorry about the long
questions
I disagree fundamentally with your
analysis okay
um I mean I I gave I gave the speech at
mansion house because I know there was a
desire and I kind of understand it but
there was desire to have a kind of a
one-word definition of our assessment of
or our relationship with China and the
point I was making is that we don't do
that with any other country in the world
for a very important reason is because
international relations are always more
complicated
than that but the point I made in the
speech there are three there are three
pillars of our foreign relations with
regard to China One is we need to
recognize the need to protect ourselves
domestically
from any kind of line influence from IP
theft from
um uh you know unacceptable activity uh
in terms of Supply chains critical
minerals etc etc so that was one that
was one column another column was
building load-bearing relationships in
the region that's a big part of what we
discussed about the IR and the IR
refresh including with long-standing
traditional anglophone Commonwealth
friends but also with other countries as
well and then the third pillar was
engaging and influencing and uh and
seeking to have a positive uh influence
on China
um using the good old fashioned patient
diplomacy skills the the the UK is
excellent at
um so the fact that the speech ran
through those domestic protections that
we needed to put in place I think I I
think shows that we have been thinking
about supply chain resilience we have
been thinking about critical minerals
I've spoken a number of occasions with
African leaders and I've said
don't allow what happened to Africa on
coffee and cocoa to happen with critical
minerals coffee and cocoa exported raw
the value add overseas and the revenue
lost to the continent of Africa that
could dearly do with the money itself I
said don't do that again with critical
minerals so I'm saying to African
leaders you should create an environment
where investment can come into your
country to process those minerals near
the point of extraction better for the
environment better for your economy and
doesn't leave you dependent on revenue
streams from overseas like you have done
with coffee and cocoa and I've had those
conversations with African leaders have
conversations with the Canadians about
their uh critical mineral
a strategy in there indo-pacific
strategies so
um I I I I understand I completely
understand I have a lot of sympathy with
the concerns you raise things we need to
watch out for
but it's there in in the speech they
gave on China we are looking out for
those things
no and I read your speech in China but I
mean I'll ask a very very specific
question is what is the government's
fact-based assessment of our supply
chain dependency because effectively the
government has no assessment has no
requirement to publish an assessment and
apart from some vague sort of probably
not great to be so dependent on China
what is our fact-based assessment of
supply chain dependency do we have one
does any government part department
produce one I don't know any government
that does have
I mean and if I'm wrong put me up on it
but I don't I I'm
apparently does according to them
oh well I haven't seen that okay um and
it hasn't been raised in the biological
conversations I've had with Tony
blinking okay about about the United
States strategy of engaging in terms of
protecting but not decoupling
um so the conversations that I've had
with our closest allies on this we are
very very closely aligned in the
recognition that we are not credibly
going to extract China from our or
indeed anyone else's Supply chains we do
need we do need we do need to have uh
the safety that comes with having a
blended portfolio that I'm a free
marketeer I never I'm never comfortable
with kind of single a single Source
supplies
um but the conversations I'm having with
our
um with our friends most both in the
immediate region and more broadly we are
we are we are very closely aligned on
this I mean I know it's early days on
this
um we are making some progress because I
think uh when Alyssa's amendment has
been accepted so the government is going
to be looking at Supply chains in
relation to defense however that doesn't
include uh dual use items and it
certainly doesn't include a range of
non-defense sightings so I
I mean
I mean doing a doing a whole economy
audit
on on Supply chains is an absolutely
Mammoth task this is why this is why I'm
this is why I want to see what the US
have produced and how much detail you
put us because because this the order of
magnitude just in the UK economy if the
U.S have have conducted an audit of all
the supply chains in both private and
public procurement I I'd be very very
interested as I say I haven't seen that
I'll be very interested in seeing that
but it's not something I've discussed
with Americans and I speak with them on
this issue pretty regularly I'll tell
you what I did a couple of years ago we
found for depending on what your
definition of strategic dependency is in
critical elements of the economy
Australia has pretty dependence on China
and 595 categories Canada 367 categories
New Zealand 530 categories the United
Kingdom 229 categories and the US 414
categories I won't go into something
well yeah but we're still pretty
dependent on them
um and so I'm happy to send that because
we have attempted to do it but the point
I'm making here is it
the danger is that if China moves on
Taiwan either intelligently by
strangling it or a sort of Putin Star by
attacking it if we then try to put
sanctions even if we're not engaged
ourselves if we are then putting the
mother of all sanctions on China for
attacking Taiwan effectively because of
our dependency now we will collapse not
only our own economy but in concert with
others the cloud the one outcome will be
the collapse of the global economy let
me just finish the question therefore
the way to deal with this a first step
is to understand the nature of your
strategic dependency on one other
country and then we can begin to do
things to encourage states to diversify
Supply Supply change to go to Vietnam or
to go to Bangladesh or to go to India or
to go to South Africa or to bring home
there we say some of this stuff here
where this stuff can be made maybe with
less environmental damage so the first
step is understanding and we're still
not willing to do that that's the point
so
I think you're rushing to granularity
that's not necessary
if if if a if an avalanche is coming you
know these countless snowflakes you know
an avalanche is coming and in the speech
I addressed the fact that disruption
across the Taiwan Strait would have a
catastrophic effect on the global
economy including China's economy by the
way
um we are already looking at making sure
that we Diversified our supply chains
this is part of not the exclusive this
is part of why cptpp
uh is so very very important this is why
we're engaging with the countries in the
regions
um and and look if if I were doing
management if I were doing resource
management and I was setting aside uh
the time of my officials or indeed any
other government officials
I I think that we could do a degree of
analysis like you put forward and it
would tell us what we already know which
is we need to diversify and that's what
we and we are already doing right so
practically what are we doing to get
firms to die final question so finally
what are we doing to to dive to get our
companies to diversify so we lessen our
dependency and our risk on one very
large potentially adversarial state
which is threatening war against another
territory or Veterinary certainly forced
reunification against another territory
which will have the mother of all impact
on the globe including the global
economy so we have been we have been
working with regard to uh
um semiconductors for example
particularly high on semiconductors
we've been doing a piece of work loss
government on that as I say I raise this
with uh I raise this with our
International
interlocutors about alternative supply
routes alternative Productions as I say
I gave a number of examples where I was
having those conversations without
Africa there's no point in US turning
around to the commercial world and say
and I'm not saying we I'm not saying it
would be an appropriate thing to say
anyway but don't buy stuff sourced from
this country if there are no other
sources available so this is why we're
working internationally to make sure
there's a diversity of sources to make
sure that we are
increasing the Diplomatic and economic
cost of bad decisions when it comes to
International aggression from where
whichever country they might emanate in
towards whichever country they might be
focused uh upon but none of these are
immediate none of these are are quick
fixes
and none of these things will be done
unilaterally and I can assure you that
this is a diversification of Supply
chains is an issue that I've raised
regularly in the United States of
America I've had conversations uh with
both the trade sector and the Prime
Minister on this on this very issue this
very much is in the Forefront of our
thinking and we are taking action in
concert with others in the International
Community to address it
there is a problem though within the
system so when I met with procurement
officials well over a year ago for the
first time they did not think that
National Security had a role to play in
their procurement Bill literally they're
like no why would this have any impact
so there is a problem across the system
it nine months them to recognize
National Security should be within the
bill and then another six months to get
any sort of amendments done which
they've now laid some fantastic
amendments themselves but there is a
systemic problem here which I imagine
Liam might lead us to I I just want to
check where on the second planet here do
you know what's happening do you know do
you know what's happened to imports from
China in the last year
uh by the tone of your question I would
suggest they probably increased but I
would also Imagine That bearing in mind
the Benchmark year would be a coping
year that is not surprising you've got a
sense of what imports from China are now
uh I I'm not I don't I don't have those
figures in my head 73 billion pounds
okay you know how much that's gone up in
the last year well as I say if the
Benchmark year is a Code Year wouldn't
surprise me if it's gone up quite
considerably well it's it's they've gone
up by 10 billion pounds it's about 15
that's how fast they are important in
China well as I say
but that's Benchmark against covidia so
so actually if you hang on so if you
look at if you look at trade across
almost every country in the world
there's an increase if your benchmarking
against covered yes that doesn't
surprise me well I'm not sure it proves
the point let me ask why it proved the
point you read the G7 communicator I was
involved in writing in Jesus so you
remember the line where it says we will
reduce excessive dependencies in our
critical Supply chains
can you just tell the committee what is
the definition of a critical supply
chain
well it's it's on things that underpin
our energy generation Our economic
foundations it's on the uh the kind of
technologies that we'll need for the
green transition for the full
um making full benefit of technological
advances uh the you know I think these
things are fairly well understood
uh well we haven't specified what they
are I don't think the government has
specified what they are and what you
just set out would account for a pretty
significant chunk of the economy but I
guess the question is if our imports
from China have just gone up by 50 in
the course of a year from a historic low
from historically well 63.6 billion
wasn't a historic low that was a record
high at the time
um are you saying that ad dependence on
critical Supply chains has gone up or
gone down
well without knowing the mix of those
it's you can't tell from the figures
that you put in front of us
well they're the ons figures not my
figures no I'm not disputing the figures
I'm just saying you can't make the
assessment without the granularity
of of what things have gone up uh of
what the Rises are compared with the
imports from others and as I say we are
conscious at the moment in certain key
Technologies there there is an
over-reliance which we have as I say
part of the G7 communicate we have
committed to address but if you're if
you're comparing
if you're comparing changes in the past
with intentions in the future you're
comparing fundamentally I think really
my question is you've signed a G7
Communicator that says we're going to
reduce excessive dependencies in our
critical Supply chains we seem to be
struggling to Define what the critical
Supply chains no we're not no no we seem
to be struggling to define whether the
dependent's gone up or gone down in the
last year no we're not has it gone
upward well I've said the figures you
presented don't prove it either way
because without without looking in a
different way let me ask the question
without without seeing without seeing
the
the specific lines in terms of that
increase in trade neither you or I just
with the figures you put in front of the
committee or the you presented to me now
neither of us can tell the point I'm
saying is the community the community
talks about the actions that we will be
taking and and your question is based on
what has happened in the past and say
you can't you can't say you can't say a
future intention is undermined by a
historic the future intention is defined
by what's happened recently I'll put the
figures to one side then
in the last year has our dependence on
China for supplies to critical Supply
chains have gone up or down
I don't have those figures to hand okay
last question both Jake Sullivan and
president Lyden have set out very clear
plans for reducing dependence on China
for critical Supply chains and between
them they're investing one and a half
trillion dollars in making sure that
they're a stronger European and U.S
alternatives
uh what are we doing now to reduce our
dependence on China in our critical
Supply chains well as I say we've got
our what's the plan we've got the
critical mineral strategy which I'm sure
you're aware of uh as I say I've had
extensive conversations with both the US
and our EU interopters and others to
make sure that we are creating
additional Parts uh for uh for things on
which we rely and the point is that this
is this is uh not a quick fix it can't
be a quick fix
um all countries including countries in
the EU including the United States of
America and others trade extensively
with China and we're all going through a
similar process which is making sure
that we give ourselves
um and other countries just as
importantly other options this is what
that G7 communique is focused upon we
have already started but it is an
ongoing piece of work and as I say a lot
of these a lot of these relative
dependencies have built over some
considerable points and considerable
length of time they're not going to be
turned around overnight and they're not
going to be turned around but they seem
to be investing and we seem to be
talking thank you well I think is that a
question or a statement no no that was a
conclusion so is that a question that
wasn't a question it wasn't a question
well unless you want to tell me unless
you want to tell me that we are
investing and we're not just talking we
are investing and we are not how much
are we investing I don't have a figure
to have at the whole point but no but
but the point is maybe you can write but
the point is the the US the EU are doing
things in a fundamentally a different
way the Prime Minister has made it clear
that we are always going to be an
internationally uh focused trading
Nation I think there are some challenges
with
um uh focusing so heavily on subsidies
regime subsidies are less predictable
they're less liked by markets because
they are less predictable than uh
Frameworks we we are producing uh sorry
we are working on our Protections in a
way which is allies to but not the same
as our us or being bonded and look if it
was as simple as throwing money at a
problem that's what everyone in the
world would do but actually that's not
what it was doing very very briefly I'm
really grateful thank you thank you
Alyssa I'm just I'm really aware that
these are not just pure fcdo questions
so thank you for taking them I just find
all this a little bit woolly you're
talking about excessive dependency I
mean what's excessive the reality is
that dependency whichever way you want
to cut the point dependency on China is
rising and a really good place to start
would have been an annual statement of
trade dependency on every and all
countries because right now it is almost
too little too late because if things
get worse in the world we are going to
be in a position where it is
increasingly difficult to do anything
about it
so I disagree with you I disagree that
spending the the uh the the the the the
time and focus on producing
retrospective reports of that
granularity will help us on what we have
already decided to do so so the the the
the the the quote that you made was from
a G7 communique so this is so this is
this is work because all of us are doing
the at the G7 we we know the areas we
know the areas where we uh need to
diversify particularly in terms of
critical minerals we've got a critical
mineral strategy we're working uh as I
say uh diplomatically in other
government departments will be doing
their uh their work to create a future
environment where we are less dependent
but but
um
but there isn't there isn't a quick fix
there isn't a simple binary Choice there
isn't a switch that you can flick on and
off this is going to be something that
we do multilaterally this is something
that we are going to be doing
for many many years to come as I say the
situation as it is today has been built
up over years if not decades and the
changes will also take years to
implement
Chris very quickly from me um the
Chinese Chinese Ambassador as I'm sure
you're aware is banned from Parliament
but you're going to Beijing how does
that match
sorry the tiny yeah so I don't see how
they're connected
well he's the Ambassador for China
that's right and he's banned from
Parliament yes by Parliament which you
which you agree with
uh yes well ultimately I agree it's it's
the speaker's decision and the speakers
made a decision on that and I completely
respect that and you agree with it I
respect that decision why do you think
it's the right thing to do if you think
it's the right thing at the same time to
go to Beijing well again so I'm not the
Chinese Ambassador I'm not going to our
Parliament I mean you're comparing two
different things I am doing what foreign
secretary should do which is engage uh
internationally there is a very good
reason that Mr Speaker has banned the
Chinese ambassador from Parliament
because the Chinese state has sanctioned
uh parliamentarians uh I think some
people on this committee and others uh
something I I am completely opposed to
and I have raised
the UK's position and my own feelings
upon this in every single meeting and
interaction I have had with
representatives of the Chinese
government so I completely respect and
agree with the speaker's decision on
that because of China's action against
British voluntarians but that is
fundamentally different to my
Duty as the foreign secretary to make
sure I seek to influence because that is
my job why don't you take including
seeking to influence the Chinese
government why don't you take Tom
chugandat with you for instance because
he's sanctioned
so basically China calls the tune no
with James cleverley China plays the
tune in your dance uh no not at all I
mean this is around I want to I really
want to nail this down the idea that a
foreign secretary interacting with
another government is anything other
than my duty and responsibility as
nonsense this is literally my job
doesn't mean I agree with them and
indeed I have highlighted the
sanctioning of British voluntarians in
every single interaction why not say you
want to take Tom tugandat with you
because because I mean it's not my job
to take out the ministers with me and my
job is to change and influence the
Chinese government you've never taken
another minister with you and that is uh
no I don't typically take ministers with
me on on on on the social meetings now
so the point is you're just you're just
a Chinese stooge then you just do what
they want
do you want to give any evidence to that
yes cool I think it presented it to you
I was pretty straightforward you've said
because China has sanctioned some MPS
you wouldn't be prepared to take them I
don't take ministers on visits with me
that's not I don't you know how shoddy
your answer is no I think I think you
have got a nice headline that you wanted
to deploy and you've got no evidence to
back it up the fact is it's the job of
the foreign secretary to engage with
foreign governments including
governments that we disagree with and we
do so to highlight the areas that we
disagree which I have done whether it be
on xinjiang Hong Kong or the sanctioning
of our parliamentarians I've raised this
issue on every single meeting and
conversation that I've had with
representatives of the Chinese
government and we'll and we'll continue
to do so so basically unless you can
give evidence to back up your assertion
I would request politely that you
withdraw it because it is not just
inaccurate it is also I think really
quite
discouraging you've had the chance when
you came to the celebrities previously
to tell us what you would do about the
actions of the Chinese representatives
in Manchester you chose to do nothing no
that's not true
what did you do what we did was we made
it very clear to the Chinese authorities
that the behavior of those officials was
unacceptable and those officials were
withdrawn from the UK so you're telling
us that it was because of your
intervention that that official was
recall to China I believe so yeah and
there was no point at which that's not
always something you've said previously
I don't think but there was no point at
which you thought that the police should
have evolved given the violence against
some of the protesters you didn't think
it should be followed as a matter of
criminal law here you gave the Chinese
the chance the Vienna convention the
Vienna convention would would mean that
that
course of action was never one that was
available to us
um
we made it absolutely clear that that
behavior was unacceptable and as I say
as like the Chinese officials this
committee is not of the view that enough
was done they could have been declared
percentage
figured me foreign
it's a very weak thing nice quiet word
in the background it's a bit bit naughty
uh kicking uh somebody very severely in
Manchester the officials
the officials left the country yeah but
you didn't expel them the official just
had a nice quiet cozy word the officials
left the country
[Music]
what further
action would you what further meaningful
action do you think could have happened
that didn't happen
the meaningful action you could have
said that your behavior is unacceptable
publicly and diplomatically expel them
for this country that would be that
would have been the position with most
Embassy staff I guess if they committed
a violent acts on the street of London
or Manchester but because it was China
you took a very weak cozy position the
officials left the country
Chinese officials left the Chinese
officials left the UK I regard I regard
that as effective diplomacy foreign
secretary the position of this committee
is however they should have been
declared right I disagree foreign
secretary because of the fact that China
then spun it as they had finished their
terms and was solely returning home to
duty and that is the problem and if we
cannot be strong at home and if we
cannot make the case that defense is not
an escalation we will be weaker on the
world stage because you cannot deter
abroad if you are not strong at home but
we are going to draw a line with this
the committee has made clear that we are
unified in this position you have made
it you are happy Madam chairman Madam
chairman
the Chinese officials involved that
instant left the country none of our
officials were expelled from China I
regard that as a diplomatic and many of
them overstayed the deadline
they would have had a longer to stay in
the UK than they say in the UK they left
UK quicker than have we png'd them none
of our officials were expelled for China
there was good diplomatic work I think
they handled it very well but the
reality is Parliament does not as a
whole degree
we're going to move to India but I think
this committee would also like to put on
record our heartfelt sympathies to all
those in India following the appalling
Railway crash that happened a few weeks
ago please sake thank you Joe and I Echo
those sentiments um foreign secretary
just want to talk about
um our relationship with India how's the
Free Trade Agreement progressing and
what are the obstacles well we are still
working on the free trade agreement with
India India is a large and complicated
uh trading relationship
um actually we have made we've made good
progress better progress than many other
countries have made with their trading
relationship it's not overlying yet we
will continue working on it
um we have of course
um taken advantage of uh a strong
bilateral relationship in a number of
other ways but the Free Trade Agreement
is not there yet
um India's human rights record has been
an issue of great Focus including Gemma
and Kashmir how's that affected the FDA
negotiations
so we we don't typically we don't
typically within the free trade
agreements put conditions on that are
non-trade related though there have been
calls in the past not just not
specifically with regards to India with
other countries to do so but but
generally internationally free trade uh
agreements focus on exclusively trade
related issues other issues we do bring
up and we consistently bring up and I'm
not saying
um
just with India but we do bring up other
areas of bilateral interest or bilateral
concern with those countries
um well if it's not through the trade
negotiations have these issues been
raised with India
have you got specific issues in mind the
human rights record in what's been
documented going on in general Kashmir
so we do raise we do raise human rights
I've raised both in general terms and
specific issues with our Indian talks is
when we have met
um
it's an entire committee is slips
um there's been great focus of course on
India's continued relationship with the
Russia with Russia and uh post the
Ukraine War uh the large-scale purchase
of a coal and oil and how they support
the Russian economy is that effective
negotiations in our relationship uh no
I've but I have raised those issues I
have raised those issues with the uh
with my Indian interopsis and I know
that other ministers uh have uh also
done so uh We've made the we've made the
case that uh Russia's actions uh in
Ukraine and elsewhere around the world
completely unacceptable that we're not
comfortable uh with that trading
relationship ultimately of course we
don't have a veto and nor would we
attempt to have veto on other countries
trading relationships but I've I I have
I have made the point that Russia's
behavior in Ukraine are more widely
casts a shadow over all relationships
that Russia has around the world
um and as I say that's that's a
conversation I've had with my uh
interruptions directly and there's been
a lot of talk about the uh Reliance or
overall lines in China
um and of course UK and India you'll
agree we both need to move away from
that Alliance in China
um is there any kind of thought given to
a supply chain resilience initiative
like we have in the UK in Australia
well I mean the conversations I've had
with India is they are they are very
keen uh to have a wider network of
trading relationships including with the
UK that's one of the reasons why we've
been uh discussing a Free Trade
Agreement about other relationships as
well they are very very uh very very
interested particularly in Green
Technology uh corporation uh with the uh
with the UK
um so this is this is this is an area
that we I have no doubt will continue to
explore and again India is the kind of
scale of economy with the kind of energy
um and economic growth that would
provide a good counterbalance not the
only one but a good counterbalance to
some of the concerns they've been raised
by the members of the committee
it's the action of other government
departments one of the obstacles to
clearing the lines of retail agreement
with India
uh
I mean India is a large uh and
complicated uh economy its Regional
government means that there are lots of
voices around the negotiating table on
the Indian side of things and that adds
complexity to it it's a big prize uh and
inevitably therefore it takes uh it
takes time all trade negotiations are
complicated the bigger the more diverse
the trade relationships the more
complicated they are have the actions of
other government departments cause
concern and issues to be raised by the
intergovernment or commission here it's
in particular in terms of Education
access and visas
our look visas is a constant refrain
from every country in the world every
country in the world would like a more
liberal Visa relationship with the UK
unsurprisingly uh having business people
tourists students come to the UK is a is
a prize for every country and around the
world so I that that is a topic
conversation in in most of my uh
International conversations that's
certainly certainly not unique to India
but has rescinding rights to work for
students coming to the UK paying
international fees to British businesses
universities
um how's that been raised as a specific
concern by the Indian government and
commission
so the India the government have
regularly
asked for a uh or VISA access a more
open Visa regime as I say that's not
unique to India but they have raised it
we have had some uh some uh good uh some
good work on getting more uh students
from India into a scholarship program
that I announced when I went to India of
having a very very high caliber Tech
leaders of the future from India in the
UK and Brits in India I know the Indians
are very very keen to keep exploring
ways of making sure that we benefit from
the top talent in our respective
countries so I mean look visas student
numbers these are regular points of
discussion not just with India but with
many many countries around the world
Henry foreign century is it the
government's position to support Canada
New Zealand and Japan joining the orcas
sort of strand B
agreement well look
um this is this is an area that that
sits across both defense and uh
diplomatic areas
um I know there is a huge amount of
interest in orcas uh from those uh
countries they're all slightly different
so for example
um uh Canada
um is not aspiring to have a nuclear
propulsion uh submarine Fleet the New
Zealand position on uh all issues
nuclear is is different to ours but they
are very very interested more generally
in making sure that we do technology
sharing there will be and I'm I'm glad
you raised this as a point because a lot
of people think purely about the
propulsion systems for the submarines
there will inevitably be a whole load
some of which have just not been
predicted not even slightly predicted
yet a whole load of other benefits that
will spill over from orcas that's why
it's such an exciting program and a
program that is multi-decades in its in
its execution and through its lifespan
will have
um a whole load of other technology
benefits both nuclear and non-nuclear
that of course uh uh our partners
internationally want to share with us
and further to that is it the intention
of the UK government to apply to join
the quad
so we this is areas that we discussed in
the Auckland meeting we've not finalized
uh that we
I mean a lot of the relationships that
we're building with the with the region
are
are strong enough and robust enough that
it might make that
it might mean that there's not great
deal of additional value so I'm not
saying no but of course we need to
assess it all these things are time
commitments in already congested Diaries
and let's say we we we're building very
very strong relationships sorry we've
got very strong relationships already
we're building on them so it might it
might make that obsolete so we haven't
made a final decision on that it wasn't
and it wouldn't be just down to us
anyway
indeed and just just finally very very
briefly once the government stance
towards the regional comprehensive
economic partnership and the
indo-pacific economic framework for
prosperity
um
so again we've we've got a number of
projects including cptpp that we've got
to get operationalized
um one of the things that I think is
inevitable that we will as we as we
uh whether it be asean whether it be
cptpp uh orcas as we get these things up
and running and operationalized I think
it's inevitable that we will look at
other Regional uh groupings uh I'm I
don't want to set too many hairs running
because again it's not just down to us
we don't get to just say I want to be
part of that and then we kind of turn up
so this will be negotiation with
Partners I think the signal that we tend
to the to the region particularly
like-minded Partners in the region is
our commitment to values our commitment
to uh uh you know high value sorry High
principles high standards this is very
much what we bring to the party
um multilateral organizations and
groupings that reinforce that of course
we are naturally attracted towards but
what I don't want to do is I don't want
to you know I don't want to start saying
yes and yes and yes and yes and yes
whilst we've still got a number of
projects that we're we're
operationalizing at the moment okay
thank you
uh just if I come to Taiwan just on the
whole office element
strikes me that the the other pillar the
non-nuclear subpillar of orcas uh has
potentially almost sort of Greater
long-term value in the sense of
broadening out to include more specific
allies Japan career Etc
do you do you think that's a valid
argument I I think there's
I mean there's so much positive
potential on this it it and and I'm I'm
glad I mean I I don't think I'm going to
say this very often but I'm glad there's
this kind of questioning of the
committee because because it does give
me the the chance to say this is more
than just about nuclear power submarines
uh there are there are there are
Technologies
that I inevitably will be derived from
this
um that will ultimately not have
applications
um within the nuclear-powered
conventionally armed submarine program
in civilian applications and others it
will it will drive a generation of
um
new skills in all three countries and
probably others it is a really really
exciting program and I know when people
think of it they think subs subs subs
and Subs that is an important part
there's so much more to this
um and and it will I have no doubt have
a whole load of positive ripple effect
non uh non-defense related uh um uh
benefits as well
can I just ask you about Taiwan uh what
is the road what role does cooperation
with Taiwan have for the UK's
indo-pacific uh strategy and to what
extent is there a trade-off between
close relationship with Taiwan and
damaging our relationship with India I'm
sorry with China
so our position on Taiwan is is
long-standing uh and you know boringly
predictable hasn't it hasn't changed we
um we have a relationship uh with Taiwan
we have a
trading relationship with Taiwan our
relationship with China is always going
to have as a foundation stone our values
and principles the case of the point
though is making two uh to others
and whilst I don't think it is uh I
don't think it is is sensible to uh have
rails and disagreements just for the
sake of having rails and disagreements
where there are areas where we feel
strongly and we disagree strongly with
China
very comfortable airing those
disagreements and airing those
disagreements directly which is why we
engage which is why Chinese people come
to the UK and that is why
um
foreign Ministers of
also go to China just like come on to
Ukraine just very briefly and you say
you enjoy answering some of these sort
of more strategic questions do you think
actually with the Atlantic declaration
that's been signed last week and with
caucus and the potential widening of the
AI and the tech elements of it
effectively we're beginning to see a
split in the world in terms of AI Big
Data high-tech
um between China maybe and China's
allies like Russia and a sort of free
world and there is beginning to be that
sort of cleavage between the two
I I don't I certainly don't think that
that cleavage is inevitable
um I think that the benefits of AI are
are huge and we've discussed the
implications they might have on
um on on trawling the vast
uh quantities of historic medical data
for example that AI might be very very
good at doing but there are definitely
risks that need to be mitigated and
those risks are not exclusively risks
that the UK or the us or other countries
like ours would would bear uh if it if
it goes wrong if it's if it's poorly
governed or ungoverned I think those
risks will manifest itself in in in in
China and Russia and in other countries
so I genuinely believe it's in all of
our Global interests and to get this
right and this is moving quick so we've
got to get our skates on which is why
I'm very very proud of the fact that UK
is hosting the first uh AI governance
Summit
um uh the the US this is something we
discussed with them pretty regularly and
I'm very very pleased that they're
engaged with this as indeed many other
partners around the world are this is in
everybody's interest to get right okay
and it's moving on to Ukraine um how
sustainable are our current levels of
Financial and Military Support
well look we
are sustainable
because the stakes
are so high that if we if we fail to
achieve what we've set out to achieve
which is helping the ukrainians regain
their country and reinforcing the
importance of territorial Integrity of
national sovereignty of the U.N Charter
of the rule of law if we fail in that
endeavor the downstream implications are
so huge and so costly both in terms of
human lives and financial expenditure
that the the the commitments we have
made now will will will be dwarfed so
it's incredibly important that we stay
the course this is a conversation I have
regularly uh internationally but we're
not it's true to say okay the uh the U.S
is supplying what 80 85 of the military
kid and dominates the financial support
as well I mean arguably we are not
sustaining the ukrainians to the extent
and their argument you hear from some
Ukraine is that they were not sustaining
the ukrainians to the extent to allow
them to achieve that victory that they
need to do
that's not a fever I mean I've just come
back from Kiev uh how to apply that for
a meeting with uh the president the
Prime Minister uh and the and the
foreign minister that's
and that's not what they're that's not
what they're saying to me okay so we are
sustaining our shells one five five
shells and indeed one five two so NATO
standard and old Soviet standard they
are still being overmatched
significantly by by the Russians in
artillery shells would you say that is
an untrue statement or a true statement
uh
so yeah the Russian army in the field is
bigger than the Ukrainian Army of the
field
which is why our support for the
ukrainians not allowing this to become a
a simple soviet-style a traditional
slugfest is so very very important what
we have seen is whilst the ukrainians
have been overmatched in terms of
numbers uh equipment numbers sorry troop
numbers equipment numbers and others
they have been much more effective in
their use of resource but both human
resource and Military material so that's
part of what we do of course we do
recognize that we have to uh both in
terms of sustainment of the uh of our
support to Ukraine and our own future
replenishment we have got to
collectively increase the scale of
production those you know the plans
around that are already being discussed
and you know those things are already
going to be put place that is not that
is not a quick fix yeah that is going to
take that is going to take time as we
gear up our production but I have no
doubt so just just on that point why why
haven't we months ago given a contract
to Bae to significantly increase 155
Supply it's relatively cheap and it
absolutely fills a very significant hole
in the Ukrainian Supply so you I mean
this is more a matter for a mod so I'm
not uh uh I'm not really able to give a
detailed answer on that there are a
whole load of reasons potentially as I
say I'm not respecter I don't know but
we do recognize that the production as I
say both for the current sustainment and
our and our future replenishment we know
that we're going we know that we need to
increase uh military uh equipment and
ammunition production rates I would also
make the point though that we shouldn't
we shouldn't allow I'm not suggesting
you are but we shouldn't allow ourselves
to be drawn into this belief that's that
that somehow Russia's capabilities are
are bottomless our sanctioned regime is
really really putting the squeeze uh on
on Russia
um their oil revenues of uh have dropped
very very uh significantly uh they've
gone into
um uh negative growth when they had been
forecast uh forecasting significant
economic growth we are putting pressure
through our and the international
sanctions regime on Russia's ability to
wage war and we're also making sure that
we're applying sanctions for example to
Iran where they've been providing
Military Support to Russia every
conference we've taken evidence in the
past from people in the private sector
and the difficulty of getting a sort of
War Insurance to underwrite their work
or their sales or the the Reconstruction
work that is starting already and the
ukrainians are very keen to have
reconstruction now despite its obvious
risks how is the foreign office working
with other bits of government to address
this so we can get some answers for our
Ukrainian friends at the Ukrainian
recovery Conference next week because
this is potentially very important and
very important for our businesses as
well as supporting Ukraine yes
um and you're absolutely right we need
to find we need to find a way of
supporting ukrainians both in the uh in
the here and now there has been an
assessment
um of their immediate requirements which
is in the region of 14 billion uh
value now I'll make the point the URC is
not a pledging conference that's not
what it's about that said
um I've been uh
had conversations where I think there
will be some pledges towards that
immediate need made at the conference
but as I say it's not a pledging
conference it is about exploring what
reassurance is the private sector would
need to start providing some of that
private sector funding for the
Reconstruction some of that will be War
Risk insurance some of it some of it
will be about what we collectively are
going to do with the ukrainians to make
sure that once this is uh once that they
once they've been successful in
defending themselves against this attack
that they don't have a repeat
performance at some point in the in the
near future so both Financial products
support from the International Community
militarily uh ultimately their Pathway
to Nato these are all going to be parts
of it
um but you are absolutely right we do
need to find credible ways of de-risking
enough to start unlocking the Taps of
private sector investment going into
Ukraine that's in large part of the URC
is going to be about thanks
I'd completely agree obviously about
Ukraine and the desire to be able to get
on with reconstruction I wonder whether
you can help me with a few things you
know that obviously
sanctioned the sale of Chelsea went
through last May is the charity up and
running and has it now got the money
from that to be able to start the
Reconstruction in Ukraine so we set up
we set up the trust to uh to to deal
with this and it's and and actually it's
we've handed that across because I think
it's it's better that it is dealt with
and with the money and and been seen to
be dealt with independently of
government when they are ready to
receive the money we'll unlock it that
hasn't happened yet they've been saying
that they've been ready for several
months now that's not what I've that's
that's not the feedback I've got there
are there are still there are still
certain issues that need to be resolved
before that can be but it's a whole year
now it's more than a year since the sale
of Chelsea and that's 3.2 billion pounds
that would be the single biggest amount
of money that we've been contributing
yeah as I say we've set up a trust to
deal with this and that is their
responsibility so so you're blaming Mike
Penrose for not having got it ready in
time I'm not blaming anybody
and
the point I'm making is that this is
is complicated the numbers are very
significant we want to make sure that
the money goes exclusively to the
recipients that it should go to this is
inevitably this is inevitably very uh
it's important we get this right but
what's the thing that's not right yet
but ultimately
uh as I say the trust was set up for
this reason is there it is their job to
to what's the thing that's not right yet
well I want it's important we make sure
that the money that's released goes to
the recipients and exclusively the
recipients that was aimed at that it was
so you're not sure that it would as it's
presently constructed well I want to
make sure I want to make sure we want to
get this right and as I say it is with
the sum of money of this magnitude I
would rather I would rather get it right
than to uh than to do it quickly and
diversity one of your colleagues said
last July in the house I think it was
that it would be sorted by the Autumn
and it's now we're here the next summer
and it doesn't look as if it's going to
be done by will it be done by the summer
recess well I don't know I don't know as
I say we're not the we're not the only
ones involved in this we need to make
sure we get this right
I think literally you are the only
people left in it but anyway
um let me tell you Chris you keep saying
that's just not the case and you know
it's not the case again I know it's good
for headline but it's just not true
it is it is honestly the only people who
have to decide whether the money is
handed over is the government the trust
so I am told is perfectly ready and has
been ready for some time so if you don't
if you're not across the details later
no no no so what's the problem with the
trust so why wouldn't we if everything
were a ticket
we've had all the assurance that we need
why would we not you're saying that it's
not ready for some reason so you're
saying that I want to make sure I I I I
I feel that with a summer money this
significant we are Duty bound to make
sure that we absolutely get this right
if your contention is that everything is
fine help me understand why you wouldn't
assign the check
no I want you to help me understand why
you're not I've just told you no I've
just told you well you haven't you are
you haven't said you haven't pointed to
a single thing that you think is
problematic with the present situation
with the trust well maybe you need to
write to us to Cloud well no I can
explain now I want to absolutely make
sure that the money goes exclusively to
the recipients and you think it wouldn't
happen and I meet and I I I need full
reassurance that is okay before before
so you don't trust the way the trust has
been put up no okay no no let me move on
to another subject then
you're trying to put words in my mouth
and those and those are that's not what
I've said and and again I think it's
really really clear that we work with
the trust we are trying to make sure we
achieve the same thing it is right that
we do it properly because of the sums of
money involved I want to absolutely make
sure right I would gently suggest that
it would also be good to be able to
start reconstruction in Ukraine because
there are people begging for homes and
this is a substantial amount of money
and it's meant to have been reading many
many months ago let me ask you a
different question which is about
um
there's there's still British companies
functioning in Russia aren't there
uh quite possibly
you would urge them to stop presumably
yes including Infosys
if so I would about I would tell
everyone to abide by the sanctions
regime that we've put in place and
mantrac as you is a partly owned by
somebody who has a British nationality
at the moment um it's still been had a
Russian based website up selling
um caterpillar equipment to oil and gas
companies in Russia presumably you think
that they should stop well it
I don't think it's right for me to
dictate to commercial entities how they
behave
beyond our sanctions regime which is
explicit underpinned by Statute so our
sanctions regime is clear one of the
things I would say is a broader point
and just as I said with regard to
countries trading with Russia I think
people should be aware of the
reputational implications of continuing
to trade with Russia But ultimately
commercial decisions are for commercial
entities we have a sanctions regime in
place we are working to make sure that
the sanctions regime is not
contravened and that we work to make
sure it is enforced but our sanctions
regime is what it is and we recognize
that that doesn't cover all activities
um and so I would be uncomfortable
demanding anything beyond what our
sanctions are sanctions demand because
that's what they're there to do I have
personal views on things but ultimately
in terms of government policy our
sanctions are clear and unambiguous and
they should be abided by
so man track is half owned by Muhammad
Mansour who gave five million pounds to
your political party at the same time as
making money in Russia
is there no reputational risk as you
just used the term
well if he's abiding if he's abided by
saying I don't know the details of the
of the trade I'd want to look into it
rather than relying just on your
interpretation of things will you write
to us then uh if there's a specific
question that you want me to answer
I'm asking you
um is it right that when you say right
you mean legal let me finish the
question do you think it is morally
right for a British political party to
take five million pounds from somebody
who has just made their money out of
Russia via mantrac
so the point I would make is that we
codify our morals through laws if you're
suggesting that this individual or this
company has done anything wrong I'd be
very very interested in any of the
details of that but ultimately as I say
our sanctions of the codification of our
view on these things
we expect sanctions to be uh we demand
sanctions uh be abided by and if there's
if you're suggesting there is a breach
of that then please let me know well my
anxiety is that we have quite rightly
sought to put in a very strong set of
sanctions in to the Russian
economy
um so as to see so as to weaken its
ability to fight in Ukraine but there is
a company that has been selling
equipment for gas and oil companies in
Russia up until very very recently and
possibly still today certainly at the
beginning of may they were which is when
I understand that the conservative party
took five million pounds from the person
who half owns that company and and that
it seems to me just seems to undermine
the sanctions efforts that we're making
but maybe you could write well you
suggest sorry I think I think we need to
be very clear on this are you suggesting
there's sanctions contradiction
yes or no I'm suggesting that the
sanctions regime may not be tough enough
um I have I don't know
I mean you're raising a specific case
and you're trying to link it to uh
donations to a political party as you
know are you suggesting that sanctions
contravention because if there is I
would be very interested to know the
details of that as you know I've been
arguing for a long time that our
sanctions regime in Russia is nowhere
near as strong as it needs but are you
suggesting the sanctions convention
with all due respect
um foreign secretary that we're the
committee you're the foreign secretary
so we're in a better place to be able to
I'm waiting for a question
I've asked a very direct question please
repeat it because I've missed it my
question is do you think it is do you
think it undermines Britain's efforts to
try and
um uh weaken the Russian economy and our
sanctions regime
if a if the British conservative party
takes 5 million pounds from a person who
has been running an organ who part owns
a company mantrac which sells and has
been selling up until very recently for
as I'm not sure whether it is still
today but certainly was at the beginning
of May when the money was taken by the
conservative party
um that uh was therefore um selling
equipment to gas and oil companies in
Russia
well the point I would make is is that
within your question you're implying
because you're making reference to
sanctions but what I'm saying is that if
if it's activity that is not sanctioned
I can't see how it could undermine our
sanctions regime if you're suggesting it
is in breach of sanctions then I think
you should you should let me know
um and and frankly the uh the nature of
the donations I I completely fail to
that's uh relevant the the UK government
conservative run UK government has I
think had one of the most robust
postures to Russia uh in the world I'm
very proud of that we've in many
instances uh moved uh more quickly than
others
um we were in close coordination with
others so again if there's a specific
accusation you want to make make it
rather than just throwing words out to
try and Link uh from what seems from
your question to be legitimate
activities but if there is illegitimacy
please feel free to say so
let me ask you one final question about
restaurant Ukraine which is and the
other potential source of funds for the
rep the restoration and rebuilding of
Ukraine is
assets belonging to the Russian state
that are presently Frozen in the UK
um you the government has undertaken to
come back to the house
um I think by September on plans or what
plans you have to in this field as you
know some of us have been arguing and
some other countries have already
started the process of seizing assets
and not just freezing I'm not sure well
there's my understanding is one other
country is exploring uh how that might
and the last time I was here it was the
best part of five months ago that
process had started as I said at the
time we're very very interested in that
this is
there's important legal principles at
stake here uh with regard to State
seizure assets freezing is one thing
seizing and disposing is another
obviously our posture is really really
clear those who are involved or have
been involved and facilitated the
disruption Ukraine should ultimately
bear the brunt of the Reconstruction
exactly how we do this we will need to
explore we'll need to have international
consistency so we we continue to keep
close eye on the Canadian case to see
how that plays out before we make any
decisions about what actions we might
take
true
tell us what the fact of the group is
uh the Volga group is a um well it's a
it's a it's defined itself as a private
military company I think most commonly
regarded as a mercenary group and we
it's over a month since it was reported
that the prescription of the Wagner
group is a terrorist organization was
imminent can you tell us why there's
such a delay in acting is it because
it's a hormone sorry that wasn't
sorry when you say reporting I think
there's speculation the media but there
wasn't there wasn't a okay can you tell
us the question's still valid well no
it's not about them because we we didn't
say we were going to so there was no
delay in fact foreign
why is it taking so long to prescribe
no foreign secretary I'll ask the
question then you can answer if that's
all right why is it taking so long to
prescribe this organization as a
terrorist group
we didn't say we were going to so you
dreams leadership campaign well the
government he wasn't a member of the
government the government has not made
the government is not the government has
not made a commitment to do so uh we we
do not speculate on future designations
you know that I've had this conversation
with the committee and at the Smashbox
before the government has not committed
to uh to do that
um but we always keep prescriptions of
this organization any other organization
under review but your your question your
question is based on reporting or
speculation as to what we might do
rather than anything from the government
let me ask you then because you've heard
are you disassociating yourself from the
prime minister's promise now what I'm
saying is the government's position well
you are yes no the government's position
has remained unchanged if the
government's position were to change I
would inform the committee but the
government's position is the head of the
government
so prime minister said this would happen
the Prime Minister didn't say this would
happen when he said that he was a back
venture
the point is there has not been a
commitment from the government that you
ask me why we're delaying something that
the government has not committed to do
so this was putting up with the question
the question the question was
self-contradictory let me get you out of
that and change taka Weaver is it your
view that prescription would be a useful
uh thing to do in terms of the
operations of the Wagner group given
they are admitted uh responsibility for
atrocities when you say migrate you mean
as a government Minister what should you
yeah as a government building as a
government Minister yeah I think or the
government minister is the government's
position is unchanged on this and if it
changes we'll let you know
have to do to be prescribed
well as I say we don't speculate on the
nature the future nature of
prescriptions the point being is that no
country has prescribed uh the Wagner
group
um we will always keep prescriptions uh
as an option but as I say we don't
routinely speculate on which uh
organizations
let me come back let me come back and
try and get an answer to the question I
actually asked you and do you answer the
question no you didn't I said do you
think it's so useful uh tool in terms of
dealing with organizations like the
Wagner group just can be a useful tool
but I comment on the fact that no
country has done so and the UK's current
position is that we have not uh
prescribed but as I say we don't
speculate on future prescription
designations what level of atrocities
would have to be carried out before you
did see it as a useful method
well look
I don't we don't speculate on future
prescriptions you you're inviting me to
speculate I said we don't
thank you
um moving back to Russia very briefly uh
can I ask where we are with supporting
cameras and the fact that he's being
held hostage specifically has he had any
access to his family and what medical
support is he receiving
uh yes the uh I mean we continue to uh
call for the release of all those uh
detained by Russian on political grounds
including Alexi uh navalny and Vladimir
caramurza
um Alexi got enough uh we continue to be
in contact with his family Leo Dougherty
who's a responsible Minister for the
region that has met with his family will
do so again in the in the near future so
we do continue to push for this we do
continue to make sure the Russian state
knows that he and other individuals who
are incarcerated are not going to be
forgotten about we are not going to
ignore them and we will keep keeping
their names in the public domain so that
Russia knows that it cannot do anything
quietly behind the scenes fine thank you
thanks um Bob
the government has said that channels
for dialogue with Russia may be
invigorated when the moment is right and
I've given our support for Ukraine
um given all everything that is going on
at the moment under what conditions
would that moment be right and can you
tell us something about the nature of
your Communications with the Russian
state currently so I have had
no Direct Communications with with the
Russian States since becoming
a foreign secretary we do of course
um still have some channels
um but
um
I'm uncomfortable speculating
what the circumstances would be for two
reasons one because I think it's it's
very difficult meaningfully to try and
predict all the
you know the variable things that might
happen during a conflict uh like what
we're seeing in a Ukraine
um and also
um
I think that the the nature or the
circumstances under which we would feel
comfortable re-engaging with with Russia
probably not ones that I've once
speculate in in front of the committee
no but I mean considering its nuclear
Arsenal considering it's a chief a
permanent membership of the security
Council do you accept the fact that it
whatever its Behavior there is worth in
having
some kind of communication with it and
at what point do you start looking to
the Future even if you're not trying to
re-engage with the government but to
what extent is your Ambassador in Moscow
who I think we're speaking to in about
an hour or the app General Russia is it
to what extent can she be tasked with
reaching out to people who have
influence in that Society even if they
are not especially if they're not
directly aligned with the regime
well obviously because of the
circumstances the actions of our
ambassador in in Moscow been heavily
curtailed she doesn't she's not able to
uh
perform the functions that you would
normally expect an ambassador to uh to
perform we do maintain uh some lines of
potential communication we are not
routinely communicating with the Russian
government and the Russian State we do
of course find ourselves sometimes
co-located I've been
um I've been in the near proximity of
the Russian foreign minister both at the
UN at the G20 in India so if the moment
were right there could be opportunities
to engage we would only do so if we
believe that that engagement was
uh either
to the meaningful benefit of the
Ukrainian people to as part of bringing
this war to the right conclusion or to
avert uh some serious other incident
that that might otherwise uh say to
avoid misunderstandings or
miscommunications we've maintain these
channels as open we're not talking to
them because you're obviously political
ahead but there are potential
communication routes which are still
open so but we do have we we do still
have an embassy uh as I say we do still
have potential lines of uh communication
and of course we would not hesitate to
to use them to as say avert
misunderstanding or seize an opportunity
to bring this war to a successful
conclusion can I just ask two very brief
questions for clarity firstly the US
have described Wagner as a transnational
criminal organization so they call it a
designation Wagner have no designation
currently in this country in terms of
being a terrorist group or a
transnational crime group or anything
like that are they so they are
undesignated yeah yeah so as I say no
country is designated them as a um as a
as a terrorist organization as per the
question those have designated them as
an international criminal organization
we haven't gone down that route do we
have that capacity to do that do we have
that designated
I mean
my understanding and I've not spoken in
detail with this uh with the American
system my understanding is that equates
to a sanctions designation which uh and
we sanctioned Wagner in its entirety so
I think it's the same I think it's
basically okay slightly different
wording but against them to the same
places okay thank you for that and
secondly just on the Russian asset
seizure in the past we've said that you
know we've Frozen Russian Sovereign
assets it is Our intention to use those
assets
to give those assets in some form to
Ukraine or to find a legal vehicle if
the Russians don't voluntarily do so
because that's what we have certainly
implied in the past what progress is
there now you say you look at the
Canadian example what progress is there
amongst G7 States about actually not any
seizing State assets but uh where's the
process and handing them over to an
international fund of some kind to
support the Ukrainian reconstruction
where are we
I
don't have anything that I can describe
as well Advanced thinking either from
the UK or from the writer G7 there are
of course some very serious legal
hurdles about the general principle of
uh
it's it's not healthy having States
arbitrarily seizing assets and
liquidating those assets
and so even though even though the cause
is as clear and ambiguous and just as
this as I say there are some very
important International legal principles
we are we will continue to explore
whether through
um legal means whether through
um
sanctions routes or whatever it might be
to get the people that have done the
damage to pay for the repair it sounds
easy
it's not as straightforward which is why
no country has come up with a silver
bullet solution to this but we will keep
working we will keep working to explore
ways of making sure that the people
who've done the damage pay for damage
actually go back to them then
well
I mean sanctions oh sanctions are not
time Limited
um and as I say there is the precedent
for freezing assets
even for very very extended period of
time is is is is well tested and say
there is difference between freezing and
seizing
um but look we're not gonna we're not
just gonna shrug our shoulders and say
it's difficult so we're not going to try
we will continue investigating and say
uh in close coordination with our
International allies
because then I'll come to Graham
um have we in our
lives well we've had very uh
Lord Peach uh who is our Envoy to the
region has had uh very clear and direct
conversations with the uh with the
Serbian leadership we've made it
completely clear that attacks against
cable troops completely unacceptable
implying that K4 somehow
involved initiating the violence
completely unjustified
um and I've spoken with the kosovan
Prime Minister we are seeking to
de-escalate this situation and we do so
by utilizing the strong relationships we
have with the leaders in the region I
genuinely pay tribute to Lord Peach very
very enthusiastic a regular
visit to the region I think he's been
there over a dozen times just since I've
become a foreign secretary and we're
delivering those very clear and
unambiguous messages to all the leaders
involved
clear lack of balance particularly in
the US is messaging on what's happening
acos over the last two weeks what's
missing us also we truly believe we're
going to de-escalate the situation you
have to call a spade a spade and yet I
haven't seen us the us or the EU call
out the armed militias in Northern Syria
who were the foremost part of the
protests if there was any legitimate
protesters I'd be surprised who through
multiple cocktails and shot at K4 who
are armed and funded by voodcich and his
Serbian forces and if you don't support
them you do what you're told you find a
Grenade on your doorstep we're about to
blow up your child why are we not
calling out these are militias we have
made it clear directly and directly I
mean this thing we
yeah we we do our diplomatic engagement
face to face and we have the standing in
the region to do so when we speak
um the the leaders in the region do
listen they don't always take our advice
which is frustrating and
we've seen some of the repercussions of
of that we have made it very clear that
we expect the demilitarization of those
um uh of those groups in the north
Kosovo area in the Border region we've
made that we've had that conversation
directly the problem is that we're not
doing it publicly so publicly the US is
used very sharpstick with the cost
sevens and really gone for them I don't
think it's a particularly Fair group of
sanctions today we you are no longer
welcome in DC we will not help you
anymore with recognition and by the way
you're out of that uh training exercise
about to take place but no public
criticism of the armed militias and the
fact that they are Serbia Hunters well
there is a balance and and this is
it's a legitimate observation but there
is a balance
sometimes doing diplomacy directly and
privately uh can be most effective their
needs sometimes to be route to
escalation if that doesn't work you do
need somewhere to go and I sometimes I
sometimes feel there is a there is a
desire to always go loud and public at
the start rather than have that as a as
a position you can escalate to as say
um the UK has real standing in the
region
um and when we speak we speak with
authority as I say it doesn't always
mean we are listen to but we are we do
speak with a real Authority a lord Peach
has had conversations directly with and
we will continue to do so and we want to
to demonstrate that a route of
de-escalation of Engagement between uh
Serbia and Kosovo
dialogue rather than uh violence is the
way forward that will be our position of
course we always deserve the right to
change our post posture and our response
based on circumstances in the moment my
view is the best way of doing this is
utilizing the strong relationship that
Lord Peter's built over the decades to
try and drive change and as I possible I
would just urge that given the US that
you are being completely unbalanced on
this and have used a very loud voice
against Kosovo none against Serbia that
is where the UK's role does come in
because you cannot have
or peace if there is a deep imbalance in
the way that we've seen over the last
few weeks Graham
thanks
what impact do you think the cut of 97
and a half percent of a quarter of a
billion pound Aid budget to the Sudan
has had on the
uh the Civil War in Sudan
uh I think the drivers of the of the of
the current escalation and conflicts
were probably independent uh of that of
course
um we would like nothing more I would
like nothing more to have a bigger
budget as I say I don't think there'll
be any Secretary of State uh in any
government of any persuasion that
wouldn't like uh more money
um the drivers of the most recent
escalation in violence are multiple
um I mean I was about to say multiple
complicated sadly they're not terribly
complicated
um but I don't think I don't think there
can be a line drawn between our odor
expenditure in the region uh and that
conflict because of course there is
still a load of money being spent
um less from ourselves but by other
countries so
um I'm unconvinced that putting more
money in whatever format into the region
would have prevented this current
escalation violence yeah
I think any reasonable person would
accept or other major drivers of the
Civil War but are you really saying to
remove nearly quarter of a billion
pounds worth of Aid has not affected in
any way what's happening in Sudan so I
think I think this most recent
escalation in violence has been driven
by by other factors there as I say uh
whilst uh We've reduced other countries
that increased and look I would love to
I would love to think that that we are
so very influential that even though
other countries were still paying Oda
money into Sudan
um that this was
um you know that we were so influential
that that our reduction expenditure
offset theirs but I that that doesn't
strike me as a credible argument the um
the friction between the two generals I
think is independent of our odor
expenditure we will of course
um continue to work with International
Partners both in the region and sorry
within Africa and within the region to
try and bring a permanent sustained
peace and dialogue between the two
generals um but uh as I say I
I can't see there's any connection
between our ad expenditure and this
conflict I mean everybody wants peace
every reasonable person one one's piece
in in Sudan
but there have been there's been
criticism of the United Kingdom and the
security Council putting too much uh
faith in the Sudan transition
process and not enough in uh the
security of people in Sudan what is your
response to that criticism
people feel that that process hasn't
been working and won't work and there
should be another Focus
well look I mean the simple truth is
that there has been a lot of effort both
from the uh from Regional bodies like
the uh the Au and multilateral
organizations to to try and drive a
sustainable peace the negotiations had
appeared to be progressing
um and the sudden very very sudden
breakdown in talks and escalation of
violence I think was a shock to many in
the international stage
um I think projecting projecting a
trying to understand you know the people
that say that we need to do more to
protect and Sudanese people how that
might manifest itself this is not a
permissive environment at the moment
we're not in a position where where
peacekeepers could go in we need to get
the uh the two generals who are the key
uh counterparties here back around the
negotiating table and bring a
sustainable piece that could then
facilitate other work but I can't see
that that there is capacity in the
International Community to inject
a security Force into Sudan
um in in the circumstances that we
currently see right I'll come back to
the intelligence
uh Dominic Ralph your predecessor had a
predatory time at this committee after
the evacuation of Afghanistan I stood
the permanent under secretary have you
read our report yeah
can you tell me having read the report
how we did better and worse in the
evacuation in Sudan when the Civil War
broke out well in terms of Lessons
Learned what lessons were learned and
what improved
so uh there were a number of
um there were a number of points I'm not
going to be able to get them all because
it was it was a comprehensive document
and I think it was it was a thoughtful
look didn't agree with all of it but I
think it was a thoughtful and important
document so
um our capacity in the crisis response
uh Center was one of the things that we
uh we've changed we made it much clearer
in terms of uh crisis leadership in
terms of
um the gold silver bronze uh the
functionality within the crisis center
and the decision making across
government
including uh the use of of Cobra in
terms of what when in terms of what went
better I I I think
it is clear that the evacuation from
Sudan
was discharged better than the
evacuation from Afghanistan although I
would say the circumstances were very
different the circumstances were very
different so you should be careful
drawing too many uh comparisons one to
uh the other but we
um we conducted the the largest and
longest
evacuation operation of
um any of the western Nations that were
that had people in Sudan
um we I think coordinated very very
closely again with regional leadership
both through the African Union and of
course with Saudi Arabia
um so that people could go from Port
Sudan to Jeddah we coordinated very
closely with other countries to
facilitate the evacuation
where we were able to of their Nationals
both in the initial
um uh under fire evacuation of
um our Embassy staff and the embassy
staff of a couple of other countries but
also the longer evacuation of British
Nationals and their suit and East
dependents
in response to that report the foreign
office said decisions should be clearly
made and communicated in advance of any
future evacuations about eligibility for
evacuation why then did eligibility
criteria for evacuation from the Sudan
change and why was the main form of
communication via email when the
internet was pretty often not there it
was it was down a lot well we we were
able to change our criteria because we
were able to extend the duration of our
evacuation flight when we first went in
there you've got to remember
the the ceasefire which was never a
particularly strong ceasefire was a time
limited ceasefire and of course what we
uh what we did was prioritize the people
who we felt we had the
um the strongest responsibility for
which is British Nationals and their get
dependents particularly
those vulnerable so we prioritize them
as it became clear that through the work
of the International Community and I
paid particular tribute to Tony blink in
the United States America
for facilitating talks which extended
the ceasefire we were able to keep the
Airhead open for longer which gave us
more flexibility and we were able to
evacuate more people and more
and extend the criteria so to the
extension of criteria is a byproduct of
relatively good news but it was
absolutely right that we prioritized
British Nationals and their immediate
dependence when we thought that we had a
very very limited window of opportunity
right
you said previously I said I would come
back to it but uh the start of this war
the two generals falling out wasn't
foreseeable and predictable
Minister Mitchell told his committed art
exactly that which is one of the reasons
why there were there's a certain level
of failure and lack of senior staff in
uh Cartoon so when you mean failure what
do you mean by that because I disagree
you think everything was perfect even
though no I didn't say anything well
what do you mean by a certain failure as
Chris said before
I will try and clarify it in a second
but it's normal for the members of the
committee to ask questions
of ministers when uh they're they're
here
there was certain
difficulties getting
people who weren't British Nationals but
who had UK residency how when their
Partners were leaving the difficulties
there that were difficulties about
communication there were difficulties uh
getting to the air bases their well
documented but the question I wanted
to ask was well you said it and Minister
Mitchell said it uh that there were
problems with early Warning Systems uh
former British ambassador to Suzanne
Sudan and other people have said this
was predictable does that mean there is
something wrong with the foreign offices
early warning systems
so I'm going to go back to the implied
question uh that you made in the
preamble to the specific question about
about difficulties and the point is we
we had to make decisions about
prioritization
um and we had to communicate in uh an
environment where electricity was
unpredictable where the internet was
unpredictable where mobile phone signal
was unpredictable so we communicated I
mean you said you said that we relied um
on email we didn't rely on email we used
all available means of communications
throughout the evacuation so we always
communicate on multiple channels because
we knew that no one channel could be
relied upon so the difficulties were
inherent within the situation
um and and they weren't they weren't
performance difficulties by uh by the
fcdo when it comes you said there were
difficulties with non-british Nationals
again they went
is they were decisions that we made to
prior to prioritize British Nationals
and their immediate families and as I
said as it became clear we could
evacuate more people than was originally
thought because we uh because the
International Community led by the
United States were able to extend the
period of ceasefire we were able to
extend the criteria these what
difficulties these were choices we took
advantage of opportunities as they
presented itself as they presented
themselves to do more than our original
planning had envisaged because we had
more time than our original planning had
envisaged
um and and again when you said there
were difficulties in the leadership I
and the reason I wanted to push back on
that is because the head heads of
mission
routinely leave the country for various
times whether it be on leave whether it
becomes conferences whether it's going
to Regional events that is not unusual
we have a well-established chain of
command
and the number two in the Khartoum when
the HMA was out was the development
director the development director took a
command of the situation in countries
there were no difficulties with the
chain of command and indeed having the
HMA able to plug into the crisis
response Center here in King Charles
Street actually proved to be a real
Advantage so I just want to nail down
those implied questions that that you
laid out before you asked your specific
question and when it came to predicting
um
the
there are always tensions uh in terms of
negotiations uh like this
but there was no country in the world
including the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
who have got very very good links into
Sudan there was no country in the world
that predicted this particular
escalation at this particular time
indeed there was a Saudi aircraft on the
ground that was destroyed with the
fighting if the if the Saudis had
predicted it that airplane would not
have been there the fact is there were
always tensions and saying oh this could
break down is not predicting
um it's not predicting
um the particular nature and timing of
the of the breakdown so whilst there are
always tensions the negotiations
basically no one not the UK not the US
not the Saudis not anybody predicted the
scale of the escalation at this
particular point in time thank you
uh going to Liam please thanks when it
comes to rebuilding Saddam our latitude
is going to be constrained because the
home office has taken so much money out
of your budget instead of all
secretaries of State wanted more
um but your budget is smaller because
the home office is using Oda to fund
accommodation costs another costs for
those seeking asylum in this country can
you just confirm to the committee how
much the home office is taking from your
budget in Oda this year
so I'm going to push back on the on the
language you use in the question
um Oda so we don't find how Oda is spent
the the definition of odor uh
expenditure is an international one uh
and we abide by that and we're we are we
are comfortable but you'll know some
countries don't take money out of Oda
for example to support those seeking
Asylum you know so they're definitely
Australia so the definition of odor is
internationally recognized and we are
not going to try and redefine that
um refugees in the UK is an
internationally recognized sorry
refugees in the odor expending country
is an internationally recognized and
appropriate uh use so when you spend
money we don't we don't say I remember
some of this is two years
will benefit the rest of the committee
is the home office is taking out of the
budget okay this year so the point is so
you keep using taking out of the budget
the point is using so the point is
we don't Define what is or is not over
expenditure we spend money on what we
spend money on the definition is
external spending money on hosting
refugees in the UK is legitimate
government expenditure of course it is
having an implication uh on our ability
to
um within a limited Oda pot expend
elsewhere I recognize that of course I
would love to spend more money but the
expenditure domestically on refugees I'm
sure you agree is a legitimate how much
is it
so um I will double I will double check
the most up-to-date figures but my
understanding is is at one point 1.7
billion in the financial year uh 2223
Okay so
would it not help us
to find other ways to increase our
overseas development budgets given the
pressures that
we've got
1.7 billion of pressures for example oh
yeah that's why the prime minister is
committed to Growing the economy it's
obviously 0.5 of a larger Quantum is a
larger budget so that is why growing the
UK economy is so important we've also
said that our aspirations to go back up
to 0.7 of gni once the economic
situation improves again which is why
it's so important that we deliver on our
promise to British people why don't we
match Japan's commitment to recycle 40
of the 19 billion in special drawing
rights that we got from the IMF
well there are the Quantum of our own
expenditure has been decided by
government that's decided at 0.5 of gni
we want to make sure that we drive down
the pressure on domestic Refugee hosting
by making sure the countries that people
leave are safer and that includes of
course bringing the war in Ukraine to a
conclusion but if we spend you know if
we spend the money somewhere it's got to
come from somewhere else especially well
the special drawing rides are sitting in
the exchange Equalization account in the
treasury and there's still money and
it's still ultimately you can't use it
for anything else and it's 19 billion
I can't use sdrs for anything else
so you can only use sdrs on uh on they
can either sit in the exchange
Equalization account or you can as you
know recycle them because you've
recycled 20 percent
so my question is why have you taken a
decision to recycle 20 and not 40 like
Japan or indeed 25 like France or indeed
25 like China but why have you come up
with this magic number of 20 percent
well the the process that I went through
with
um both actually when I was developed
when I was the minister with the lead
for development prior to become a
foreign sector in the exercise that I
went with uh went through with Andrew
Mitchell balance is our International
commitment I don't have the extensive
folder full of spreadsheets that
underpin the decision making on that but
the point is that
um the idea that somehow there's this
free Port of money implicit in your
questions is Freeport of painless money
that we could apply to this we choose
not to it's just not accurate all money
has to come from somewhere and all
matters and there's always an
opportunity cost to any uh expenditure
what we want to do is we want to grow
the British economy so that we can get
back up to the point seven percent of
gni
um and also until we get to that
increase to 0.7 whilst we sit at not
less than 0.5 we want to make that sure
that that 0.5 is of a bigger figure
either way our incentive is to grow so
at president macron Summit next week in
Paris what proposals are we tabling to
grow the size of the development pie
globally
well I don't want to I don't want to
preempt the negotiations that will be
that will be happening
um at that Summit but the point is
the best way of being more generous
internationally is to grow the size of
the economy I'm very proud that
under this government Even in our most
constrained Year we're able to put a
higher percentage of gni than any labor
under any labor government so in our
worst year we did better than the
previous labor government's best year so
I'm very proud of that but the best way
of doing even more still is to grow the
economy and everything circles back
sustainably to grow the economy and
that's why we're focusing actually you
could match what Japan's doing thanks
Jeff thank you so much Neil
150 Palestinians and 20 Israelis died
last year alone in part due to tensions
over settlement expansions can you just
talk us through what steps you're taking
to stop Israel annexing further land in
the upside West Bank
well uh our conversations with Israel
have made it clear that we oppose any
actions which
potentially undermine a sustainable
two-state solution that includes
settlement expansions we've raised that
I've raised that directly with my
Israeli interlocutor and I know that
that message has been passed across
number of channels across government
so that's a conversation and but what
meaningful initiatives are you working
on to de-escalate the conflict well
conversations I mean diplomacy is
Meaningful initiatives that's how much
change is derived in the in the world
and we do work uh say both directly with
Israel we work in uh coordination with
other International Partners we have
um let's say a very good relationship
both with Israel and other countries
in the region and Beyond and we are
consistent in our message that we want a
sustainable peaceful two-state solution
that it sees over both the Israeli
people and the Palestinian people we
will support activity or initiatives
that support that agenda and we will
oppose those that potentially undermine
it and that and we've had this
conversation I've had this conversation
directly we don't believe that
settlement expansion supports that
agenda that's why
why is the UK government opposing the
icj referral on this YouTube
what's the basis for the UK position on
that
because I don't believe that that is the
most effective way of driving change in
this
um the the conversations that we have
had and there have been you'll remember
a number of occasions in the past where
there has been talk of or commitment to
settlement expansion and through
diplomacy through negotiation we've
prevented those expansions and we will
continue to seek to do so but the
difference is the Israeli government now
has a coalition now has a commitment to
expand and would you consider
um action against British companies who
are either demolishing even UK Aid built
uh support for Palestinian refugees in
particular but also engaged in building
illegally for Israeli settlements
So when you say British companies that
have been yeah involved in demolition of
existing Palestinian facilities on
Palestinian land or in building Israeli
settlements it disputed or occupied
territory well the the our position on
uh trading with Israel and companies
uk-based companies or UK companies that
trade with Israel are able to are able
to do so
um
ultimately as I say our position is that
we feel that settlements expansions is
detrimental ultimately to the desire for
a sustainable two-state solution that
continues to be opposition
okay what was there to stop the public
concluding and we had uh so Chris
touched on man track earlier five
million donations to conservative party
and no action against uh mantrac
profiteering from a legal war and again
here JCB 5 million donations of
conservative party involved in building
Israeli settlements no action for the UK
government let's just stop the public
concluding that five million pounds a
nation allows a blind eye from
government
if you're making a specific accusation
make it I just did I think well in which
case all the donations to the party look
I'm here as a government Minister rather
than the spokesperson for the
conservative party but worthy party
chairman here he I'm sure would say that
all the donations to the conservative
party are done in full accordance with
the Electoral commission law and full
transparency and if you are making an
accusation of uh bribery in any way then
please do so
um I'd be very interested to hear you
actually say it rather than just imply
it I'm asking because you've said that
you have these conversations I'm asking
for what action you're taking against
those who are pursuing the expansion and
annexation of settlements and you're
saying you have a conversation but I'm
seeing no action I'm just exploring why
there might be one action
so you're saying they see no action I
made the point that on a number of
occasions where there has been uh well
Advanced talks about settlement
expansion through diplomacy through
diploma we can show your head all your
life through diplomacy yeah
so if you want to move on please do
through diplomacy we have prevented
those expansions from uh happening
because that is how diplomacy works we
don't always get away in every instance
but that is how diplomacy Works eight
minutes to go we'll continue to engage
to try and drive a positive change both
in this region and more broadly I'm
going to bring in Royston now
quick question foreign secretary if I
may um 1975 the signing of the Madrid
Accords ended the Spanish presence in
modern day Morocco but still the
westerners areas contested
does the UK support Morocco's claim to
the Western Sahara if not why not and if
so when publicly so uh
so we we our position on this is that we
do not recognize the Moroccan claim to
the Western Star I've had we enjoy very
very good bilateral relationship with
Morocco this is an issue that I've
discussed with the Moroccan foreign
minister uh on a number of occasions
um so our position is unchanged
ultimately we want to see this as is the
case with a number of other issues
around the world we want to see this
resolved through dialogue and
negotiation and we will always seek to
encourage dialogue negotiation but
that's All That Remains the UK
government position
foreign
[Music]
we support self-determination over the
future of sovereignty of our British
overseas territories such as Gibraltar
and the Falklands well yeah also
opposition opposition on those overseas
territories has remained uh the same
I've made the point specifically with
regard to the Falklands recently after
Argentina unilaterally withdrew from
number uh from an agreement around this
bottle position on this remains
unchanged
so if the position of the British
government which I would argue correctly
is for self-determination over the
future sovereignty of overseas
territories like Gibraltar the Portland
Islands Bermudas Cayman Islands and
others why is that not the case for the
camera for the um for the British
overseas for the British Indian overseas
territory
so uh we as you all know there have been
ongoing proceedings uh legal proceedings
with regard to the definition of uh
sovereignty of British Indian overseas
territories you'll know we are in
negotiations with Russia's to try and
resolve this in a way that protects all
the things that we need to protect
um and the uh you know the the UK's
government position is that this is the
incredibly important to us
we abide by international law and that
is why we are that's why we're
discussing uh with the government of
Mauritius a sustainable solution to what
is currently a disagreement and just
very briefly finally
um are you aware one of those
protections that I know the fcdo talks
about is countering Chinese growing
influence in the Indian Ocean are you
aware that the immersion government has
recently chartered a Chinese vessel to
transport between Mauritius and one of
the outer islands of the British Indian
Ocean territory Paris banners uh yeah I
I have heard reports of that and
this is why more broadened looping
background to the initial questions that
the committee posed this is why our
increased folks on the indo-pacific is
is incredibly important we actually
enjoy a good bilateral relationship with
Mauritius we want to make sure that they
don't find themselves as other countries
have done
in a relationship a debt relationship
with China that unbalances their uh
their their Sovereign governmental
decision making
but we will we will continue to make
sure that through these negotiations
we stay very very clearly focused on the
um both the immediate geographical and
The Wider geopolitical issues which we
seek to protect I think I can give you
and the committee assurances on that
the U.S inflation reduction act
subsidies are presenting clear
opportunities in the hydrogen economy
and we know that the EU is working hard
just now to access the supply chain
there Scotland has a rapidly uh
developing hydrogen industry what
specific work have you and the Prime
Minister done to ensure that Scottish
industry can access that
so I've
um I mean I've discussed uh UK US
trading including Scotland
on trips to the United States of America
I'm very proud of the fact that I am
Scotland's foreign secretary I'm very
passionate about promoting Scottish
business Scottish Innovations
specifically on the hydrogen opportunity
have you done any work there so I I have
raised business opportunities with
Scotland so not not exclusively about
hydrogen so not not specifically on that
but have you had any discussions with
Scottish government ministers about
taking this forward so I have I had a
meeting uh what was it it was a while
back now with Angus Robertson uh about
promoting of Scotland overseas and so
I'm very very proud
it's the important part of the job that
I do so so renewable energy
and Renewable Energy Technologies are
something I discuss regularly not just
the United States of America with
countries around the world one final
question you said you had a discussion
with Angus Robertson when was that I
need to double check my diary of it as
well right now it was uh last year right
about this year last year was it last
year no I'm asking was it last year I
can't remember the top of my head okay
thank you
yeah and the arrest of Russia ganushi
and other people in Leonardo movement
I'm really concerned about uh the attack
on political pluralism and Company on
the Democratic rights in the
Constitution that came about after the
Arab Spring just very simply what is the
fcdo doing to get Russia ganushi
released from prison and other members
of the United agreement so again I mean
uh
Tunisia looked as if it might be the
good news story from
um from the Arab Spring it is
disappointing uh to see uh the progress
they have been making uh slip backwards
uh we we have engaged I'll double check
on the most recent engagement is on that
I don't have the detail that would have
been done uh would have been uh
it's not something I've raised uh
personally with him by note this is
something we feel strongly about and of
course we want to see pluralism we want
to see democracy meaningful democracy
Engineers who will continue to push for
that
new
thanks Jeff and can you explain more
concerns if foreign office or British
High commission have raised with the
Sierra Leone government about imminent
elections there
so I missed that I was distracted I
missed the question fast approaching
elections in Sierra Leone and in your
letter to the committee you said whether
our concerns you've raised them with the
Sierra Leone government what concerns
have been raised well I uh I've had
Direct exchange with the president of
Sierra Leone
reinforcing our desire to see open free
and fair elections uh in uh Sierra Leone
I think since the time of uh military
government in Sierra Leone there has
been a move towards a democracy but I
wanted to make it clear that we are
watching that we want the best for
Sierra Leone but that we do expect uh
free open and fair elections in Syria
and so I've done that directly and I
know this is a conversation that is
echoed at high commission level and did
those conversations include issues about
registration intimidation of Voters
anything specific or were they more
generally about retaining democracy so
uh the I mean I can double check on the
nature of the conversation this
conversation we have regularly so the
High Commissioner had conversations on
these issues when I visited Sierra Leone
I had the conversations on these issues
uh directly with the uh um Syrian
government and they're saying I've
exchanged uh Communications with the
Sierra Leone president reinforcing this
but our letter very specific concerns if
you could go back and look at what the
discussions and then send back because
your reply didn't cover any of the
specifics so just be interested to hear
well as I say I I mean I was telling you
what I directly have done I'll double
check on what specific points been
raised by the High Commissioner
obviously High Commissioners because
they have a more regular interaction
with our interlocks is we'll go into
more detail than I will do at foreign
sexy level but I have raised I have
raised our focus on Democracy Sierra
Leone directly with the president okay I
look forward to receiving further
questions but then I wonder about this
fraud against the foreign office in
Sierra Leone so two million pound going
missing the context of dwindling budget
and perhaps you can talk us through how
this has been
even possible to occur
you know so it's still being still being
investigated obviously we have missions
around the world in countries with
different practices in here and some of
those have corrupt crap practices this
was clearly a case where individuals
working for us were properly selling
selling fuel which they shouldn't have
been with now spotted it we're looking
exactly what happened and what that
tells us about our controls around
around the world I wrote to the chair as
you as you know appear in our not only
accounts any you know any fraud is is is
regrettable and we're you know
determined to find out exactly what
happened in any lessons we need to draw
more widely across
across the network
stopping this happening uh again in
Sierra Leone does it not uh you know
ReSound the alarm about the undermining
of democracy and we're all brought in
that country by the government party
potentially
I I wouldn't I don't think it
necessarily draws any lessons for wider
uh politics or governance in in Sierra
Leone you're saying this is specific to
individuals within the foreign
commission yes
um Chris
a couple of quick ones uh first of all
and thanks very much for what Andrew
Mitchell said about
um the new um anti-gay law in Uganda and
I presume that you completely endorse
that it was just choosing which minister
to say it yeah oh yeah look he's he's
the minister for Africa yeah and so he
said I raised it directly when I last
met the uh Uganda eye commissioner as
well Grand thanks so much the can you
confirm have we been funding the um
inter-religious Council in Uganda
you might not be across the details if
you haven't could you just write to us
to tell us how much so I will I will
double I will double check uh on that
let's not get it half right if you could
write to us that'd be great just because
obviously it will be distressing for a
lot of people to think that we've been
funding a profoundly homophobic
um organization in Uganda for the last
few years it'd be nice to know how much
money we've been giving
and if we haven't then we can cross that
off different one
um the golf strategy fund as I
understand it um we doubled the amount
of money going to Saudi Arabia and
Bahrain last year
um some of that money is going to the
ministry of interior ombudsman
but there are lots of allegations that
they have been deliberately covering up
torture in Bahrain why on Earth would we
be giving money to Bahrain to do that
well we are building capacity to make
sure that the legal functions in Bahrain
and other countries in the region
improve
um and actually we have seen uh
significant changes particularly with
regards to the
uh the use of non-custodial sentences
particularly with regards to
um people under the age of 18. so we
have seen improvements that have been
made I raise I raise the issue of Human
Rights regularly with Michael golf
counterparts when did you last do so
again I'd need to double check I need
someone can you just send us a list of
the times when you've raised human
rights issues with
um Gulf States leaders when uh that'd be
great if you could I can do but to make
the point this is a regular part of the
conversations I have so sure it's
typically good to have it all on the
record so typically it would be in in in
a vast majority of the interactions I
have my ghost golf playing and find one
for me
um the last set of transparency returns
that the foreign Commonwealth and
development office returned was for up
until last September you're now nearly
six months late why is that and why is
the foreign office nearly always the the
officers you're meant to do it within
three months of the date concerned
so so for instance there are no
transparency returns about your time as
far enough in the foreign office yeah
I'll look into that yeah and you're
nearly always the last Department
and and the leader of the house has said
that you're meant to be doing it within
a month
um by the summer recess so it'd be good
to see how you're going to get on with
that uh well uh I will I will look to
see I will look to see what uh what
happens to that I mean my
I would imagine that by the nature of
international travel and the H5 job our
returns might be more complicated than
other government departments but I will
I will look into that I would prefer to
be fair to be best in class and final
two foreign secretary what is your
assessment of the ongoing normalization
of Assad and also connected to that
question asthma al-assad which is
obviously the wife of
her father is a known Captain Smuggler
here in the UK and yet there seems to be
no effort to make sure that Captain
doesn't make its way to the UK
particularly given that Afghanistan and
Ali opium is being raised to the ground
what are we doing to stop Captain coming
here but also to sanction people like
the Assad regime and his family who are
still here operating British soil and
traveling to Syria at least every other
week
well I'm I'm uncomfortable about
speaking
specifically about individuals but I
have raised the decision by the Arab
League to re-admit Syria I had extensive
conversations with a number of my Arab
interpreters in the weeks and months
leading up to that I knew this was
something that they were considering I
think the decision is largely
actually I shouldn't put words in their
mouth I know that
some of the pressure of Syrian refugees
in the region is is a part of that and I
think there is a desire to or a belief
that it's better to
um Enterprise Syria away from Russia for
example
um I've made it clear that we are
uncomfortable with that obviously it is
not our decision to make as an Arab
League decision the UK's posture has not
changed I recognize some of the drivers
for that decision even though I don't
necessarily agree with them and
certainly don't like the decision and we
will continue working
with our partners in the region to try
and drive stability in Syria obviously
the Syrian border regions particularly
the west where it borders onto uh
Lebanon
um and particularly the north where it
borders onto uh onto turkey and Iraq
these are these are
um
I mean these These are
these are challenges uh it's an
incredibly difficult file and one that I
spend a lot of my time working on but I
say the UK's position remains consistent
and will encourage our partners in the
region uh not to
um not to to to to
allow Syria Syria's reintroduction to
Blind them to some of the changes that
Syria and the Assad regime really needs
to drive
and I'll leave that request sorry I
smile said oh Father
and their final is is a foreign office
uh resisting holding up refusing to
allow the prescription of the ilgc which
we understand home office wants to do
and as part of that can you also assure
us is to position a more out of us who
remains held illegally by the Iranian
government who again whose Health would
greatly concerned about as a committee
so the second Point uh second Point
first we continue as as we always do we
continue to work uh to get the full
release of those people illegitimately
uh detained in Iran this is a
conversation
um that uh that I've had with the United
States of America and we continue to
have with the Iranian regime and the
protection of British Nationals overseas
will always remain a priority for the UK
um with regard to prescription
um
decisions about prescription are always
cross government
decision government speaks with one
voice and unless the government position
changes the government's position at the
moment is uh is that we have not
prescribed the rgc as a terrorist
organization as I said in response to
other questions on this we keep these
issues constantly in uh under review and
if the government's position were to
change then the government would then
speak with one voice about this changed
position as it stands at the moment the
government if the foreign
government on this and I'm not going to
get into where people are because uh
discussions within government are Best
Kept within government until decisions
are made then they are communicated as a
single voice
committee for reports a strong request
to the foreign office to give a green
light to irgc prescription uh can I give
you both our thanks for coming before us
today and for giving up your time and we
will write to you on a few issues were
raised today but thank you both ever so
much order order at the end of this
session